at long last the first full trailer for
venom has arrived the film which focuses
on Tom Hardy as journalist Eddie Brock
is the second big screen appearance of
every comic fans favorite alien symbiote
after the first teaser of the film
conveyed more about the tone of venom
than its actual content fans finally
have their first real look at what this
movie will be about and more importantly
what Venom's iconic costume is going to
look like this time around the venom
trailer shows us glimpses of Hardy's
Brock the villainous life foundation and
plenty more
amid the explosions alien symbiote
attacks and sinister narration there are
a number of key plot points and details
the trailer offers that you might have
missed the first time around here are
some of the small details you may have
missed in the venom trailer a lethal
protector there are a ton of great
comics that depict venom as a hero
the most notable recent ones don't even
feature Eddie Brock in the starring role
as such there are only so many venom
comics from which the film could draw
inspiration and from the trailer it
looks like the film will be a loose
adaptation of venom lethal protector the
90s miniseries sees venom and Eddie
relocating to San Francisco as fugitives
from spider-man and the authorities they
do so under an agreement that as long as
they don't hurt anyone and stay out of
Spidey's business spider-man will stay
out of theirs the book features them
taking on Carlton Drake in The Life
Foundation both of which appear in the
trailer voice of the people
fans that the character may find
themselves pleasantly surprised by the
direction in which venom takes Eddie
Brock when it comes to his career choice
the prior big screen incarnation of the
character from spider-man 3 depicts
Eddie Brock as a photographer and a
pretty skeevy one at that from the looks
of it venom will set Brock on a
different path one with ties to some of
the characters best comic appearances
the Eddie Brock will get in the film
looks to be an investigative journalist
a career the character had in the
original spider-man comics where he
first appeared the venom lethal
protector comic series further
establishes Brock as having been
inspired by journalists to coverage of
the Watergate scandal which gave Brock
an underlying anti-authoritarian streak
if you translate the film very well it's
a smart decision
for a version of venom that looks to be
more antihero than supervillain as an
investigative journalist Brock should
have a strong sense of right and wrong
and we get a look at his willingness to
make bad people uncomfortable in the
name of truth in the venom trailer it's
a great character decision and bodes
well for Brock as a likable protagonist
a dapper villain the venom trailer also
gives us our first real look at the
film's villain
Carlton Drake played by RZA men Drake is
another carryover from lethal protector
albeit one with which the filmmakers
seemed to have taken a few liberties in
the comics Drake is an older man running
the life foundation he's a shady dude
but he's not responsible for Veneman
Eddie's bonding nor for the discovery of
the original symbiotes although he does
discover the existence of others it
looks like a meds take on the character
will be significantly different Hamed is
young and attractive and by the looks of
it he'll be a prominent media figure in
the world of the film
he's also far more directly tied to the
symbiotes presence on earth with his
life foundation seeming to be
responsible for either discovering the
symbiotes or bringing them to earth to
begin with it makes for a villain far
more directly tied to the protagonist
and that's likely going to be a good
thing love is in the air we get our
first look at the dynamic between Tom
Hardy's Eddie Brock and Michelle
Williams and weighing in the venom
trailer as well and the comics weighing
is Brock's ex-wife even though they
appear to be together in the cinematic
take their relationship may still be a
bit complicated since in the comics she
also eventually gets a symbiote of her
own and becomes the villainous schieben
with multiple symbiotes at play in the
film let's not rule out an appearance
from that particular alter ego just yet
a complicated relationship the
relationship between a host and the
symbiote in Marvel Comics isn't
necessarily defined by a strict set of
rules but generally speaking there is
usually a decision made on the part of
the host to bond with
why would we do that here it's not clear
how much of a choice Eddie Brock has
about sharing his body Eddie doesn't
even seem to understand what's happening
to him during the bonding process and
when his venom powers are finally
unleashed on the men who come to his
apartment looking for their boss's
property he seems just as shocked by
what happens as they are it's a pretty
cool storytelling choice one that opens
up possible explorations of body horror
and Eddie's loss of autonomy as the
hosts cemented by the symbiotes chilling
line so venom will not only have a mind
of his own in the film but also a voice
we hear him speaking to Eddie in the
trailer
since there are obviously two distinct
and separate characters that happen to
occupy the same body we're all in for
the inevitable struggle for control of
dominance between the two one giant leap
for mankind
the Venom symbiote origins story of the
comics is a little bit complicated but
basically spider-man finds the Venom
symbiote while he's in another dimension
fighting in the beyonders secret wars
with the rest of the Marvel Universe and
since Peter Parker's being shared
between Marvel and Sony it looks like
venom is going to cook up its own
streamlined origin story instead the
venom trailer seems to reveal that
rather than Eddie discovering venom
through spider-man the light foundation
does it also skips the element of
Venom's origin where it masquerades as a
superhero suit the alien that the
foundation discovers is impure symbiote
form there appears to be no intended
trickery on its part the audience and
the film's characters will see it in its
true goopy form from the start and a
goopy venom is a happy venom thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]